all right y'all welcome to the season 2
premiere of the kelly clarkson show
give it up for america's dad bob saget
thank you so much mom
i love you kelly clarkson i love you
buff sagat i love him so much he's
awesome
the last time i was on this stage was
over six
months ago and a lot has changed for you
for me for all of us uh let's just get
this out of the way
2020 has been a dumpster fire yep just
all the word i can't say on this show
just piled together and it's on fire
that's really what it feels like
so from day one um i i
did though say that this show is going
to be about connection and not even
2020 and socially distancing ourselves
and all the hurdles are going to get in
the way of that we are still going to
stay connected
and i wanted to sing those classic tv
songs
because in hard times when we're
separated it's the nostalgic moments
with families and and friends that hold
us together
um and well you've just been stuck with
them if you wanted to or not so
um plus we've all been on lockdown you
know with
nothing else to do but really binge
watch the old shows because we're out of
all the new ones because nobody can tape
anything it's fine
so give it up for my band y'all they're
back
looking so fly we are all back together
band crew
all of us and we are here in our studio
finally
we've really been looking forward to
this i know everyone is in their own
worlds with their jobs um but a big
thank you to my tv friends who join us
today ed
asner from the mary tyler moore show
george witt
and john rosenberger from cheers and
david coulier and jody sweden from full
house
thank you guys so much and as you can
see we have a new kind of audience as
well
this season these are actually our brand
new house seats
uh filled with people from all over the
country for example we have leah dialing
in from her home in columbus ohio wave
leah what's up
oh i love the color red wear a great
color yes all right and over there is
eleanor from raleigh north carolina
give it up come on eleanor give us away
all right well this is all thanks to our
partners at the video call center
we're actually the first to use their
new crowdview technology which is super
cool
uh that means any of you watching from
home can actually use your cell phone or
your laptop and be in our audience which
is actually kind of cool we're leaning
into how we're navigating
the new way but just head to kelly
kellyclarksonshow.com to find out how
you can be a part of this fun fantastic
moment that we're having
um i'm so glad i can still connect with
all of you though um in my studio
because as you probably know 20 20 20
has brought a lot of change also to my
personal life
definitely didn't see anything coming
that came
but what i'm dealing with is hard
because it involves more than just
my heart it involves a lot of little
hearts you know we have
four kids and divorce is never easy um
and we're
both from divorce families so you know
we we know the best thing here is to
protect our
our children and their little hearts so
i'm usually very open
and i usually talk about everything but
in this case i will talk a little bit
here and there about how it affects me
personally but
probably won't go too far into it
because you know i'm a mama bear and my
kids come first although i do love you
all
but i am okay everybody keeps asking are
you okay are you okay
and i am the answer is yes it's one of
those things that it's okay because it
matters it was something important
and i know a lot of you um at home
unfortunately probably been through it
either as a kid
or um just as yourself in your own
relationship so
i feel you and it is a bad connection to
have with people
but um i will say this though when i
when i got upset when i was a kid
i had a problem like saying how i felt
and my mom told me to start writing
and that's actually how i get my
feelings out so i probably won't speak
about it too much but you definitely
will hear it musically probably um
that's how i became a songwriter
music's always been my outlet to help me
get through difficult times
and this year i've been listening to a
lot of music and i've also been writing
a lot of music as well so
this week we decided to dedicate to
music
it's dedicated to musicians and it's
dedicated to the way
music heals all of us and we've got a
lineup of unforgettable performances you
won't want to miss
and i've been told there are some
surprises even if i don't know about
them very excited
all those surprises make me nervous but
it's fine